we've got a baby on the way we do we
really do I have 82 days until I can
have a martini but who's counting well
it's Martini time Kate Chastain's
officially a mom Hallelujah the below
deck Alum welcomed her first child she
revealed the exciting news back in
December I've been very lucky easiest
pregnancy ever
from what I've heard I've not been sick
I've only craved Donuts
um so as eager as I am to be able to
like have a drink again and have my body
back it does occur to me that I'll also
have a baby when that happens you know
what you're having right but you're not
sharing I do know what I'm having but
along this journey I'm holding on to
things to keep it special because I've
never done this before so I'm airing on
the side of caution without giving away
what you're having what was your
reaction to finding out I was relieved I
was very relieved
and that could be interpreted either way
and Kate has shared her journey as a mom
will be a solo one but she's yet to
explain how it all happened I wasn't
planning it but I was hoping for it
um
it is a happy miracle and I would love
to share every detail with how it
happened and everything but I think I'm
gonna be a good mom because I'm
realizing like this is not just my
information like my unborn child one day
will have access to the internet and
we'll be able to Google and I just feel
like it's not just my information to
share that's a whole nother thing that
will cross when we get to that bridge
but um yeah so that's that's where I'm
at hot Jesus he's not the dad
yeah
no that would make the version Mary
no that would make me Jesus's Mom I
don't know I've not seen hot Jesus in a
while you're never drinking alone with
Jesus that's what my grandma always said
as far as what kind of Mama Kate will be
well she does have experience in the fur
baby department is Halo ready to be a
big brother he's loves kids so much he's
I am so excited for him oh and fully
expect the former yachty to bring some
Chief stew energy to Motherhood I am
going to be a strict mom they might not
love me the whole time but they're gonna
give me a great speech at the wedding
you know because I I believe in manners
effort is what yachting is about
everything should be perfect all the
time without asking so if my standards
are high they should be there's a thing
called gentle parenting like no we don't
punch mommy like no it's gonna be go to
your room and learn how to act Chiefs do
energy in the mom life right congrats to
Kate and her little bundle of joy
[Music]
thank you
foreign